[Music]
bob never left a room without giving you
a hug and a meaningful hug like nuzzle
his head into your shoulder kind of hug
this is why we're here
this is why i came back this is why
i'm his favorite
you know it i am i can't say that yes
you can it's okay
the most comforting part is all the
relationships i have with everyone and
all of us um talking like the full house
family and
kelly
bob's wife and and aubry and laura his
daughters we've all been in really close
contact and that was strangely one of
the most unreal weeks of my life from
the week that he passed up into the
funeral because we were all together
every day
practically 24 hours a day
kelly rizzo posted this beautiful
tribute to bob sharing moments the two
had together with the caption i can't
even put into words how much i will miss
this i thought of this interview i did
with him on the very last day of filming
they are
really friends of mine the girls they're
not girls they're they're women and
they're smart
and then i talk to them and ask advice
and they do the same with me you're
making me cry david tanner you just did
it that's what danny chandler does and
then he hugs you when it's over thank
you
nobody hugs like bob
you see the pride you see
how supportive he is i mean he was
welling up just thinking about us ladies
and um
he's just a special such a special
person candace was 10 years old when she
first met bob on the full house set in
1987. we got to witness firsthand the
bond she forged with her tv dad and it
would only grow stronger over the
decades common mark
the very first time i directed fuller
house bob was in the episode but it's
been known on set when the when the
three guys are there everything takes
twice as long because everyone's
laughing everyone's joking he looked at
me
and he was like i know what you're gonna
say you don't even have to say it i am
going to be on my best behavior you are
going to love me even more
after we do this episode because i will
do whatever you ask me to do and um and
he did he was always so proud of all of
us girls i mean his own daughters he's
just was always a gloating
father he was just like i want to make
you shine so what can i do and that's
that's who bob was at his core now a mom
of three herself candace is keeping busy
the latest in her aurora tea garden
series aurora tea garden mysteries
haunted by murder premieres february
20th on hallmark movies and mysteries
and this installment flashes back to
aurora's past with a twist teenage
aurora is being played by none other
than
my daughter natasha which was pretty fun
and the teenaged sally character is
being played by lexa doig who's the
actress her real-life daughter mia it's
totally haunted it's not haunted there's
no such things
we were the biggest stage moms ever our
biggest note to them
we had to tell them we're like
you guys are too cool
we're really we're really dorky
[Music]